[Music]
i've known guy raz for a very long time
we actually went to college together so
we've known each other since we were
teenagers
and he remains to this day one of the
most inspiring people i've ever met
his ability to see through a situation
and understand the complexities
of how things work and how people work
continues to amaze me
and so it was incredibly fun for me to
have one of the most popular podcasters
in history
come as a guest on my podcast what a lot
of people don't know about
guy is that he used to be a war
correspondent he has been in harm's way
multiple times plus he's also talked to
many entrepreneurs about what it takes
to start a business
so he understands this concept of
courage from many different angles
so that's what we talked about courage
how to find it
where it comes from and what to do with
it this
is a bit of optimism
[Music]
the thing that i wanted to talk to you
about is courage
yeah and the reason is because
most people know you for your podcasts
and especially for how i built this
where you talk to people who have
the courage to do extraordinary things
in business but what i think a lot of
people don't know about you
is that you used to be a war
correspondent yeah
and you used to embed with the military
in some of the most
dangerous situations that were happening
in the world
and i thought you're unbelievably well
qualified to talk about courage
there are i think different types of
courage we are living in a day and age i
think right now
where people are finding courage where
people need to find courage
the courage to stand up the courage to
challenge the status quo the courage to
speak
one's truth the courage to demand change
the courage to ask for help the courage
to have difficult conversations
you know it's it's interesting this
topic of courage is something i've
thought about
a lot over over the course of my life
and i think the reason why
simon is because i have never thought of
myself as a courageous person
and i don't say that to be falsely
modest in any way
for me courage was always a pursuit
it was always something i wish i had
more of and it's funny i used to talk to
my wife
about this a lot and i remember one time
she said to me
how can you not see yourself as
courageous you you know
you've been to iraq and afghanistan and
covered the balkan
wars and israel-palestine and have been
to
incredibly violent places where there
was gunfire around you
and to me it's strange because
going to do those things i spent you
know
six months in iraq in 2003 and then many
months and 0.4050607
and several visits to afghanistan and
pakistan and most of those trips were
not embedded with the military
you know you were kind of freewheeling
and i remember the first time i went to
afghanistan
was a week and a half after daniel pearl
was murdered
and i was 26. maybe
and i was the npr berlin correspondent
and
i was sent to go to afghanistan and i
had to fly to islamabad to pakistan
where npr had like a
house there like a staging house i
remember it was four in the morning and
i was leaving the house and
arriving into the house was the outgoing
npr correspondent
who had just come out of afghanistan his
name was michael sullivan
and as the first time i met him i was so
nervous you know but i i was trying to
be brave
and uh i said oh how is it there how
does it seem he just looks at me goes
watch your ass kid and i was like okay
and he said i knew danny pearl really
well and
i get into a car and go to kabul and
you know i was scared to do those things
but
it didn't immobilize me with like i
could do it because
it was part of my job you know part of
my job was to be a foreign correspondent
and to bear witness
i was a reporter the hardest thing for
me to do
in life has been to have difficult
conversations with people
to confront people
i don't relish confrontation i always
prefer harmony over confrontation
i've always been afraid of tense
situations with other people for fear of
the way i would react
so that's the kind of courage that to me
is much more challenging it's it's a
much higher level of courage
because it's the courage to examine
not to examine yourself but to be
prepared
in a difficult conversation for the
relationship
with the person to be worse afterwards
you know
and i have always had a hard time with
that i just don't like it i've never
liked it
for me harmony has always been like the
thing that i pursue
i think sometimes to my detriment
because if you're only pursuing harmony
you're kind of
sometimes papering over bigger questions
and issues that go unresolved anyway
a long-winded way of saying i have
always
struggled with this idea of courage
what's so interesting i think about
courage a lot too
and i've always believed that courage is
external
that you know you and i have both had
the honor of meeting people who have
risked their lives to save the lives of
others
who thought that they would probably die
in doing so
and through some miracle didn't and
when i've asked them why did you do it
no one ordered you do it no one would
have faulted you if you didn't do it
you've got a family you've got kids why
did you do it they almost all say
exactly the same thing which is because
they would have done it for me
yeah and none of them think of
themselves as courageous yep they think
that's what anyone would do so that's
what i would do
and they would do it for me or that
there's a mission there's a higher
calling which you talked about i was a
reporter i was there to bear witness
yes yeah and you know i always joke
around that we don't have the courage to
jump out of a plane
unless we have a parachute on our back
it's the external thing it's the
parachute
that gave us the courage to go and
having a sense of
purpose a cause to wake up for in the
morning
we are able to to find the courage
that other people might perceive as
courage yeah but for us it's simply
following the path
that we've chosen to put ourselves on
it's exactly right but
when it's having a difficult
conversation it's not our job to have
difficult conversations
yeah so now i understand why you call it
courage because now i have to go deep
inside where before it was a path i was
on
or the belief that someone was there for
me it was it was a social contract yeah
you know it's a really interesting point
because when i
and i guess we should mention we go way
back we went to college
we went to college together we took the
too many years to count yeah
when i graduated college i wanted to be
a reporter so
so much and i know this is like now a
kind of a trope and a well
worn trope that people say but i really
truly am an introvert
in the classic sense that i and i think
you are too a little bit which is
completely
even though we do public jobs we do
public speeches i speak in front of
thousands of people and
do events and and have this job i i
really when it's over
i i just need to collapse into in a dark
room and go to sleep it's really
hard for me i love it i appreciate it so
much but it's um it doesn't come
naturally to me
so i i was never the kind of person that
would walk into a party
i think like you two and be the center
of the party like oh there's simon
there's guy let's gather like i'm not
the guy at the irish bar
telling the the stories and you know
jimmy fallon is one of those people he
is just a natural at it
it's incredible so i was never the kind
of person who could just walk up to
somebody even now i have a very
difficult time
going up to people just saying hi i'm
guy how are you let's make conversation
because
i can't connect the dots to continue the
conversation
there's some wall i hit i just i start
talking to them and i even when i try
i get to and and then and then it's i
hit a wall
i can't keep a conversation going and
there are lots of people
who have the opposite ability right who
have this talent
here's the thing to be a reporter you
have to be
prepared to go up to anybody and ask
them
any question and i think the reason why
i was attracted to becoming a reporter
was because the minute you put a
microphone because there's a radio
reporter from the beginning
or a notepad i could go up to anybody
and if they say
you know go bugger off or you know
whatever it is they might say to you to
me it's fine
in my personal capacity if i walked up
to somebody in a social situation and
they just
said look i'm just not interested in
talking to you i would be so personally
hurt
and embarrassed that i wouldn't know how
to respond
but somehow as a professional going up
to somebody with a microphone in my hand
or a notepad it's no problem all of a
sudden at age
22 23 when i started professionally
reporting
it opened up this whole world to me i
think it's why i was attracted to it
because
it was a way for me to actually do
something that
i really wanted to do which was to
interact with people which was to find
out
about their stories which was to talk to
them and get to know them but i couldn't
do it in my personal capacity
it's so interesting my my life is very
very similar i didn't know that i was an
introvert because i'm not socially
well i am socially awkward sometimes but
i have a big personality
and so others mistook me and i mistook
myself for being an extrovert because i
have a big personality
but i love susan kane's definition of
introversion versus extraversion which
is it's about energy
yeah which is an introvert wakes up in
the morning with five coins
and every social interaction they have
they spend a coin at the end of the day
they're depleted
where an extrovert wakes up in the
morning with no coins in every social
interaction they have they get a coin at
the end they feel rich
and when i spend time with my friends
who are extroverts we go to a party and
they are like
as soon as we leave they want to go out
more
you know when i leave a party first of
all i always leave early i always leave
early and i just want to
i just want to go home and do nothing
yeah but i'm
just like you which is if i have to talk
to someone
about i mean about anything if i need to
find something out about who they are
what makes them tick how does that go
i can start a conversation keep it going
i have insatiable curiosity i ask good
questions i ask
pointed questions but in a social
interaction
where i have no pursuit
i go up to a person they may introduce
themselves and i don't know what to say
yeah and i'm so self-conscious about it
as well
because i'll just stand there and smile
and nod and like
beg and hope that they say something
yeah because otherwise i'm just gonna be
like
okay well very nice to meet you and walk
away going they think i'm an idiot
but this idea of pursuit which is when i
have
pursuit i'm able to call upon and very
naturally i might add it still might
exhaust me but i don't
there's no internal dialogue there's no
strain
yeah so this goes back to the the first
challenge
that you raised which is you don't
perceive the things that you did
in going into a war zone yeah
as courageous even though the rest of us
absolutely would i concur with your wife
that is you know for the rest of us it
is courage but for you because there was
a pursuit
and so it goes back to the question you
raised before which is the thing that
you find very difficult and i think
the thing that a lot of us find very
difficult is how to start
a very difficult conversation knowing
and i like the way you put it that at
the end of this conversation
it could be worse yeah or if it's
professional
it might be someone losing their job
yeah or it might be someone
feeling better or it might be pointing
to someone out
something that they don't want to know
about themselves but
they really need to know this about
themselves and the relationship could
collapse
yep and so how does one do that like
what is the pursuit like how do we have
pursuit
so that that becomes something that
human beings are better equipped to do
it's a really hard question answer
because i think most of us are wired
to avoid or i think to avoid conflict i
think so
i don't know if all i don't know if
that's true but i think so
i mean guys that's a different
personality types we either want people
to like us
yeah or we want to make sure people feel
okay i wanna make sure you're okay
yeah i think few are the people who
don't care about
how i feel and i don't care about how
you feel so i'm just gonna do it yeah
i mean as i get older it gets a little
bit easier but i have probably
spent too much time in my life worrying
about
what people think of me and really
wanting to be liked by people
and i think in part because like most
people we are usually our own worst
critics we're usually the hardest on
ourselves
yeah i'm really compelled by this idea
that to find quote unquote courage
that there has to be a pursuit because
that makes whatever
struggle you're about to go through
worth it
right like the need to bear witness is
more important
than me running away to safety or
anything else that we do where we're
uncomfortable
although we may not feel uncomfortable
in the time and this idea that
our ability to have difficult
conversations to find the courage for
confrontation
is actually the pursuit is not the thing
that we're talking about but it's about
self-examination and personal growth
that if i am
in the pursuit of self-examination then
in order to
be on that journey i have to have these
conversations because at the end of the
day
none of us live in a bubble we're social
animals yeah and whether we like it or
not
introversion and extroversion aside we
have to interact with other human beings
we have no choice and success in life
is a successful interaction with other
human beings and that doesn't mean
everything's happy
that means successful interaction is
knowing how to navigate
complication and tension as well
successful marriages are not absent
tension
just the successful marriages the couple
are willing to meet it head-on and go
through it
yeah but again the pursuit is i think
self-examination i need to grow yeah and
i think that
it's like we all live in our own movie
right and we're all
constantly like seeing that movie from a
very distinctive perspective
our own perspective our own perspective
that is
usually wrong yeah right like even the
story we tell ourselves about who we are
is a version of who we are but it's
very different from someone else's
version i'll give you an example
i have this impression and i think part
of it is just
intentionally like suppressed memories
of
really hating high school and
recently a high school friend of mine
got in touch with me because you know
she here's my show and
found out i lived in the bay area and
got in touch with me and
she was a good friend of mine high
school um and we lost touch after high
school she went to ucla and now she's a
psychiatrist
and we were on the phone and i said um i
just i really hated high school i just
i i have really bad memories of it just
being lonely and
it was a big high school to a 3000
person high school i was the
editor-in-chief of the high school paper
but my memory is of being um just you
know another kid in the crowd and she's
like really hated high school she's like
you had so many friends everyone liked
you and i was like
whoa what are you talking about and then
she told me this story
that i didn't even remember until she
told me she said you were
and i'm telling you the story because i
i promise you
my own story of me in high school was
as kind of a standoffish aloof
kid who was kind of too cool for school
i never went to football games and never
i didn't go to the senior prom
i didn't participate because probably
because i wanted to participate but my
response to it was those things are
stupid and i'm not going to take part
so i had this perception of kind of
being like a negative person
and she said i remember one time our
senior of high school
do you remember she said we just took
the day off we just skipped school and
we went skiing we went to mountain high
outside of l.a and i said yeah i think i
remember she said
and do you remember i could barely ski
and we went down like
one hill and i was just doing snow plow
all the way down and you got down
and when i finally reached the bottom
you were waiting there for me with a cup
of hot hot chocolate
and i did not remember this is a friend
of mine i didn't remember at all she
said you were so nice you were just such
a nice person in high school and i was
stunned i was like tell me more i need
to know this
these memories are totally locked away
you know and so
that's also part of the challenge that
we
face as as humans that we have these
narratives that
are so real they are the truth to us
you know like i think about this with my
kid simon my kids who you've met
i love them so much but sometimes
and maybe more than sometimes my kids
set me off i
and i love them and i you know and i do
a children's show so i'm like there are
lots of kids who listen to me
on the show and and know me my character
on the show
but like i'm also a dad and so like i
can get
really really mad at my kids when they
do stupid things or they
do something that you know they can just
set me off
right whining whatever whatever it is
right and
i'm sometimes i will i work hard on
trying to control it and i count to 10
and
thankfully my wife and i are on the same
page and you know but i can just lose it
sometimes i get really mad
and i have this fear that one day
the narrative that they will have is
like daddy ucl or daddy used to get
really angry is instead of like
the hours and hours of time that i spent
like
playing with them or like throwing
pitches or working on their hitting
or throwing footballs with them like i
thankfully i get to work from home so i
see the kids
outside of the school hours i see them
every day and and really do
to try to engage with them but i still
thought like god one day i'm gonna have
a conversation with my kids and they're
gonna be like yeah dad you were just
you know that's who you were and i'll be
like what what are you talking about
isn't that part of sort of the
the magic and frustration of life which
is my friend george flynn
calls the moments of truth there are
these fleeting moments sometimes
minor little things that have
massive impact in the lives of others
that we don't even remember that we did
good and bad i might yes yes yes that
time that you walked past me
in the hall and waved and and said hi to
me i've never forgotten that you're like
uh yeah okay you know and you gave me
the courage to do something because
and you're like uh yeah well you taught
me how to be a good person because you
were standing at the bottom of the hill
with a cup of hot chocolate and we don't
realize
good and bad the power that we can have
in the life of another human being
yeah and so i guess the pursuit is then
you try and be a good person
all the time but even getting angry is
like that one time that you told me
you know you told me off and i i'm
really grateful that you did because
nobody else would have
i mean like we have no idea no idea how
it's gonna be perceived
and one of the things that i find so
interesting even you telling me about
your own narrative of yourself because
you know it's rare that we get to have
conversations with people
where we've actually known each other a
million years and we interacted in
college together because we were both
involved in student government and
i remember you
it's so funny that you say that you were
afraid of confrontation because i
remember you
standing out in a crowd i remember a few
other people guy
that i interacted with in student
government yeah and i remember you
specifically as having absolute courage
to speak out and speak in hard words
for the things that you believed were
right and you were
you were very outspoken and
uncompromising
in doing the right thing and so i
remember you as having more courage than
everybody else
to have difficult conversations and have
confrontations it's interesting
it's possible that that's true that you
know especially in college
i was able to articulate ideas
with less fear than i can do as an adult
like if today
i mean i can sit on a stage right and be
interviewed or talk
to a crowd of people but i'm prepared
for that conversation and it's usually
a fairly friendly crowd right like
that's people are coming to see you
but if i was in like let's say the
oxford union you drop me in the oxford
union right now
and the forum has opened anybody to
speak or like a ted conference
and you just hand me a microphone in
that audience i
i i don't think i could do it i think it
would be really hard for me to stand up
and just extemporaneously say something
because this is the courage part i think
this is comes back to the idea of
courage
where i think i lack courage to this day
is
i'm still vulnerable to the fear of
judgment by outsiders you know even at
this point in my life in my mid 40s
parent you know two children grown man
successful career
i still do want to be judged positively
by people and i think that's really what
i struggle with
especially when it comes to this idea of
courage i don't have the courage to say
screw it i don't care you know i'm just
gonna
say it i don't care what people think
about it i really do care about what
people think
i think that's half true and of course
i'm overlaying my own experience
as you're speaking yeah and i am the
same
i don't think that i have courage to
speak out the same way other people do
because i want to make sure them the
message is right
yeah but then again i know that i have
this reputation
for saying very uncomfortable things to
people
in meetings or on stages yeah and so i'm
trying as you're speaking i'm trying to
reconcile these two things and it goes
back to pursuit
which is yes i have pursuit for my cause
that when i say those uncomfortable
things straight to someone's face in a
meeting
truth to power at no point do i have
any trepidation because it's no longer
about me and it's no longer about them
it's about something that's way more
important than both of us yeah whereas
when it's something else and it becomes
about
something small or worse about me
then i can be completely stuck and
literally not know what to say
and i think that you could stand up
in front of a the oxford union in front
of a potentially unfriendly audience
with no agenda no subject matter and be
compelling
if you gave yourself a cause
or pursuit on that stage and that's by
the way one of my stupid human tricks
which is before i give any talk no
matter the size of the audience no
matter
the composition of the audience i will
be backstage and i will say sometimes
out loud to myself you're here to give
and it reminds me that i have an agenda
i have a vision and i'm here to pursue
it and if if i'm caught off guard and
somebody says hey can you just say a few
words the way i'll compose myself for a
second or two before i
speak is you're here to give take an
opportunity this is a new audience go
yeah and i think you can do the same
yeah i think that's right
i know you can this is not like a
motivational talk no but i think you're
right when there's a purpose behind it
you know when there's an external
purpose or an external
pursuit we've been pulling a pursuit
which i really like yeah it's doable i
think
and i actually think that right now and
i've recently been
doing this as well on my show on how i
built this
you know we're a really important moment
you know we're in a moment where
um we are all of us
especially all of us white folks have to
get comfortable with the uncomfortable
in a way that is going to be and
hopefully already is
really unsettling to sit down
and hear and listen and also to spend
time
trying to understand things that we just
didn't
for for most of our lives i liken it too
like what's happening now in the
conversations around privilege
and around history and around memory and
around
wealth equality and systemic
institutional racism
i sort of liken it to what's happening
with i think a lot of
whites in in the united states is
they're sort of like you know when
you're you're on your your computer
and all of a sudden that like rainbow
circle shows up and it starts to just go
and go and you're like oh my god can you
please hurry up i'm in a hurry
and the computer is just like the
rainbow circle like
i think a lot of white people are in
that rainbow circle they're processing
a lot of information right now and it's
extremely
important but it's also very frustrating
for
most african americans most black
americans who know these things
know these truths live these truths and
in many cases haven't been believed you
know their concerns have been diminished
or minimized
the way they've been treated have been
brushed aside and not taken seriously
and now we're in a moment where there
there must be
a total reassessment and reevaluation
of our narrative right our own personal
narrative
the narrative that we have believed
about
our country the united states a
willingness to
completely tear that narrative down and
reconstruct it
and you know basically i i think
a need to sort of surrender to surrender
to
truths that many white people in america
you know i don't think always for
nefarious reasons but just they haven't
been willing to do so and i think that
that
is something that you know i don't want
to overstate it i don't want to overuse
the word courage but i do think
that it will require a level of courage
to reshape how we how we think about
this country
our history who benefits because if we
can't
do that we can't change it you know what
i mean the thing that i think was so
different about the murder of george
floyd
to your point is it was the first time
you talk about being in our own movie
and narratives and
you know what we believe when when
stories of police brutality
you know come out in the news what we
saw
was uh photographs of the aftermath
or a blurry interaction of we don't know
what
and there was the one account and then
there was the police account
and because most of us have you know as
a white male
the interactions i've had with the
police in the past has been very
different
than my black male friends who've had
very different interactions with the
police
and so that all factors into how do i
assess this
and the the murder of george floyd was
so different because
we saw the entire scene
from beginning to end with multiple
camera angles
for the first time ever as a white
population
we saw what a lot of african-americans
have known for a long time
and there was no double narrative there
was nothing
there was no fuzzy aftermath it was
there crystal clear
that's what it was and there was no
uncertainty yeah
and i think that the frustration
among so many black americans is that
it took the george floyd video to wake
up
a sizable portion of the american
population
i mean the very hard thing for
most people to reckon with is that
within all of us lives racism
it's very hard for us to say that
because
the word racist in america has you know
to many people mean somebody burning
across wearing a white hood
and so you know the old trope i don't
have a racist bone in my body you know
you always hear that from somebody who
said something
incredibly racist the reality is racism
lives
deep within us we have been exposed to
images and ideas from
the earliest times in our lives that
shape the way we see the world and
to deprogram that to unravel that
is really hard work yes and i think that
people can more easily
accept that if we accept
that we all have judgment yeah and we
judge people
every day and i mean we do it at work
you know somebody underperforms we go
what is their problem
you know and we have judgment about
all kinds of things including someone's
appearance
and we are all judgmental and so
the question isn't i don't think how do
you cease to be judgmental
because i think i think this goes to
pursuit right i think this goes to
pursuit which is
no one will ever be non-judgmental but
we can pursue
that ideal because the whole idea of
pursuit is that you never get there
but you get better and better and better
and better and it's your thing about
growing up and getting older
which is i don't think we're different
people i think we're better versions of
the person we're trying to be
if you want to be on that journey yeah
and to have the uncomfortable
conversation with yourself
i was too judgmental or i judged too
quickly
or i need to learn to hear first
before rendering judgment find out what
the back story is
listen and i think that idea of
listening
it is the best solution
to avoiding judgment yeah so the courage
is not the confrontation it's not having
the difficult conversation
the courage is the willingness to start
and
or be in that conversation and then say
nothing
and also to be in that conversation i
think and
understand that you may hear things that
make you feel really bad yeah and that's
really important
you know that is a truth yeah and
there's accountability right
yes which is the judgment part is a
human thing and we want to mitigate that
and we want to get better and better and
pursue being less judgmental
our whole lives but when we are to
accept accountability
right i think that we are especially
americans right we are
naturally optimistic and by the way it's
it's a very uniquely american thing like
you grew up going to britain
the average person in britain isn't
inculcated in the culture to think like
i'm gonna grow up and be the prime
minister i'm gonna grow up and be a
billionaire like in america it's a very
american idea that like it's always
gonna get better
europeans make fun of us europeans make
fun of americans for for the unbridled
optimism
for the unbridled optimism i think i
think that's been changing over the past
few years
i don't want to kind of be a caricature
of the american optimist but i will say
that
this moment to me feels
very encouraging in the sense that there
are conversations
that are happening now on huge platforms
in mainstream media that would have been
considered
radical a few years ago
you know conversations about reparations
about how to
how to begin to confront a real
reckoning it's really a much more
mainstream conversation
i think more and more people in america
particularly whites in america are
understanding that
the wealth creation of this country is
not something that happened overnight
it's something that happened over
hundreds of years
primarily because of free labor because
of an enslaved population that built the
foundation
of that wealth who never benefited in
that wealth
it's instructive to i think sometimes to
examine how other societies have
reckoned with their past not to compare
tragedies or to compare experiences i
mean
south african apartheid and the rwandan
genocide the holocaust and jim crow and
enslavement
and you know the terrorization of black
americans each of these
stories is unique and each of these
stories
stands alone but in many cases around
the world there have been attempts to
reckon with the past imperfect most of
the time
imperfect even in the case of germany
where
they banned any public symbols of nazism
they
there are no statues to nazi leaders or
no
there are no memorials to nazi nazis at
all
you can't fly the swastika germany paid
cash reparations to holocaust survivors
it doesn't mean
that it eliminated racism and
anti-semitism in germany they exist
it doesn't mean it made germany a
perfect country it is imperfect it
doesn't mean that
there aren't germans who bitterly resent
the fact that they
are constantly reminded by their own
country of the crimes of their
ancestors but it is something
it's something right um in south africa
there was a truth and reconciliation
commission it didn't
bring about economic equality it didn't
bring back the dead but it was something
and in the united states we have had
nothing i mean even
even well-meaning presidents like jimmy
carter who is a deeply
empathetic person we've never had a u.s
president i mean
who who has felt able to
at the very least begin a conversation
about
the original sin of america's founding
and i think that that that has to happen
that there's a first step that has to
happen
human beings are funny because it we
have
ingrained in us it's innate a desire and
a sense of fairness
you know children from a very young age
yes oh yes and especially if they're
siblings
oh yes you know that's unfair
that's right right yeah and sometimes
it's a somebody gets something
and somebody else doesn't or sometimes
it's in punishment how come you're not
yelling at them
we have innate it's ingrained in us
because we didn't teach our kids
fairness they're so young when they
start using and having a sense of
fairness
and balance and equilibrium and the
statistics are alarming i can't remember
the exact numbers but they're it's
something like
70 or 80 percent of malpractice suits
are simply because the doctor refused to
apologize
yeah yeah that if the doctor simply said
i am
so sorry there would have been no suit
yep
and you think about it there are so many
ways that people avoid saying sorry
because it's
so hard because sorry is a mirror
that says you did something that hurt
someone
even if you didn't intend it you still
did it it's like that old keystone cops
it's like you're holding a plank of wood
and you turn
you turn and you bunk somebody you know
you hit somebody you if you want to do
that
you still turn around and say oh i'm
sorry like you still take accountability
even though you didn't mean it
yeah and it just happened to me just
yesterday
that i got sort of a kind of apology my
favorite is when people say i'm sorry
but well that's not an apology the
minute you say that you've
negated the apology but the one i got
yesterday
was friend we had an argument and
she didn't want to talk about it and so
she just basically said
i'm going to talk to you tomorrow i
don't want to talk about this and got
off the phone very abruptly
and she texted me and said i apologize
the phone call ended abruptly
and i thought to myself that said that i
like i i thanked her
because i knew what she was trying to do
it's a step it's a step
you know and i wanted to i wanted to
acknowledge the fact that to her that
was an apology
but she'd never said i'm sorry i was
difficult or i'm sorry i ended
the phone call abruptly it was too hard
so i'm sorry
the phone call ended abruptly you know
as if it was cut off because we lost our
sell signal and i think
if we struggle to apologize to our
friends
for the actions that we take that may
make the situation go south
then how is a society where do we find
the courage
to say i'm sorry for what we did i'm
sorry for what my ancestors did
even though i had no part of it well
just like i didn't intend to
to bonk you with my briefcase with my
umbrella
and by the way even when you say sorry
it may
not actually have an
immediate impact in any way the example
would be
with germany i mean my grandmother
and my grandfather who lost most of
their
family in the holocaust who were burned
ashes
they shuddered when they heard germans
spoken if they heard it in movies
they shuddered they were so fearful of
they would never step foot in germany
i lived there for three years so there's
a enormous difference like
of course i saw horrible germans but i
also saw wonderful germans and really
came to admire so many things about
germany
now i'm just two generations removed
from the holocaust
when i was a kid my parents had friends
who would come over
who are now my age in their mid-40s who
had numbers on their arms
i was six seven years old i remember
that i'm now they're
i'm 45. i remember that they were my
age but the fact is is that
you know an apology to somebody i
understand that that
often requires courage but it's doable
it doesn't
actually and especially in a personal
context
saying sorry or thank you to somebody
it's free
but it's so damn hard it's so so damn
hard yeah and there's two sides of this
coin
because there's the courage to say sorry
and accept responsibility
and there's also the courage to accept
that apology that's right there's two
sides
yeah and sometimes it happens where one
person musters the courage
there's a pursuit of something here to
take full accountability and say sorry
even if unintended or
not personally involved in the case of
history and
what do you do when the other person
doesn't accept it it's very hard and
that's
i think that's part of the fear of
giving an apology yeah because
because if you're left apologizing and
there's no acceptance of the apology
that is the most vulnerable you can be
yeah
and forgiveness is also very difficult
and we know
from millions and millions of research
papers that when you forgive somebody
it's actually
something you do for yourself but it's
still very hard yeah
you know i'll be honest with you like
it's conversations like these
for me where somebody who i love
and trust who
[Music]
you know i know i can have a
conversation with and you and i you know
the nice thing is we've reconnected
after many years
and what's so nice is because there was
a background because there was a history
instant friends and yours and my
friendship has only gotten deeper and
you're one of those
few people in my life that i i know i
can talk about absolutely anything
without judgment if anything you will
get in there with me
to try and understand what i'm trying to
understand with me
and this conversation has been exactly
that for me
this idea of courage has to have pursuit
i think is fascinating and then when
there is pursuit you actually won't need
courage
because you just want to do it yep like
i had this great conversation with maria
shriver
about service what it means to live to
live a life of service
and i made this comment that service has
to have sacrifice
and she pushed back and said absolutely
not
because if you're the one doing the
thing and it's the path you're on it
never feels like a sacrifice to you
that's right struggle maybe
suffering maybe but not sacrifice it's
only a sacrifice like how could you've
given up that to do that
to others they don't want to be on that
path they see it as a sacrifice for you
you just see it as an illogical next
step
yeah and i think that's what pursuit
does
i think pursuit makes having that
difficult conversation or doing that
difficult thing
the logical next step that to others
they perceive as courage
but to those who do it of course you do
it
like those servicemen and service women
who risk their lives to save the lives
of others in that moment
it was just a logical next step yeah and
in every case i know you've experienced
this
i remember when i spent time with
with soldiers and marines and i would
say why are you here
and you know you would occasionally get
the pad answer you know to protect and
you know
the freedoms of my country and i said no
really what why why would you die and
it's always
look man i'm just here to protect the
guy in my left and my right
every time it's as simple as that it's a
very clear
idea i mean yes it's practicing and the
flag and maybe some of that stuff but
really it's about
making sure the guy on your left and the
guy on your right doesn't get killed
it's camaraderie yeah
and it goes back to why should we go
through this why should we go through
this
conversation this national conversation
this struggle
right now and it is there's a pursuit to
have these difficult conversations even
if they're difficult on a one-on-one
level yeah
not at a societal level because we've
been given a pursuit by our founding
fathers
all men are created equal pursue the 244
years later we're still pursuing
but i think because it is we have no
choice but to live amongst each other
we are tribal animals we're social
animals
and it's person to the left and person
to the right that's why it's worth it
at least it is for me yeah no question
about it i mean i think ultimately
that's what it's about
right yeah we're at this moment now that
is really
unsettling and it's not only because
that the pandemic and the economic
crisis
it's because of so many factors that i
can't
fully articulate but i think most people
will understand what i'm talking about
it's a moment that
has sort of culminated in this political
period 2
where cruelty and
this absence of just empathy and i know
it's going to sound
really simplistic and forgive me but i
believe this
just an absence of kindness is just
really
and i'm not saying that that it we were
kinder or more empathetic or
what beforehand i although i do think
outwardly we were in some ways but i
think we're we've been in a moment for
the past three years
you know with the election of trump and
and the people around him that
has really kind of opened the floodgates
to
just just a kind of a level of cruelty
that um and meanness that
makes me really sad and i hope
my hope is that this moment is also
instructive for all of us that this
should not be what we want
we should want to live in a
in a place where in a country in a
society where
we are making sure the person on the
left and the right to us
is okay it's not that hard
it's really not that hard it can be done
you know
i hope that it can happen in this
country i hope that
this period will have shaken us in a
different direction i don't
i don't know if it will i think it will
i think that
this one is that the response has been
different everything about this one's
been different
and i think that this is one of those
things like stepping into attention with
a friend
or a loved one where you say i don't
want to go through that again but i'm
glad it happened
god i really don't want to go through it
again no no
no oh my god
and this is the problem with pursuit
right because pursuit isn't ideal
none of us is going to be perfect none
of us is going to get it right
society individual society just
collection of individuals who get it
wrong on a regular basis
yeah and you just hope you hope that we
can look around and
ask for help lend our help
and take accountability when we get it
wrong
and that's the pursuit all right let me
ask you this question
i mean the infinite game the whole
premise of that book is
to keep playing the game and so by its
very definition
it's an optimistic book right because if
you're playing the infinite game
you believe the game is worth playing
and worth playing infinitely
and i wonder because i i do this very
optimistic show how i built this
i did ted radio hour very optimistic
show
i do wow in the world very optimistic
show it's about possibility
i love the idea of possibility
but i have to confess that that that i
go through periods of
deep dark pessimism you know where i'm
really discouraged about the future and
it's hard because i'm a parent i've got
to
be optimistic because i've got two
children and i want them to
live in a world that's better so i
wonder how you
think about optimism versus pessimism
given
that the nature of your work is
optimistic you know people think because
i'm
optimistic i'm i'm blind to me optimism
is not the denial
of the reality around me it's the belief
that the future is bright
that i'm in a dark tunnel and instead of
focusing on the darkness i choose to
focus at the light at the end
and i cannot tell you how far away it is
and i can't tell you how long it's going
to take to get there
but all i know is that i can see the
light and that's the direction we have
to go
but i can still accept and acknowledge
that that this is dark
and difficult and my footing is
uncertain because i can't see the ground
and so for me optimism is the belief
that i'd rather walk with my head
looking forwards than my head looking
down
and instead of worrying about i don't
know how to take the next step
to be confident that if i stumble that i
have people with me who'll pick me up
because i promise to do the same for
them
because i don't believe you can reach
the light
alone and that doesn't mean that i don't
sometimes feel down because of the state
of
where we are or feel bad because
you just continue with the metaphor that
we're tired and exhausted and it's dark
and my knees are scraped up and i'm
hurting
and the thing that solves for all of
that is someone who says
i got your back i agree and this is why
you understand courage
because you've been there and you would
not have had the courage to go
into a war zone as a journalist if there
weren't hundreds of
thousands of journalists who'd gone
before you you might have been by
yourself but you didn't go alone
it's true to be a part of something
you know i i cannot stand it when
politicians invoke the future we have to
do this for our children
right because if if we really made
decisions for our children we wouldn't
make half the decisions that we make
right but it's for our past
we cannot let those who went before us
let their struggles go in vain that we
have to uphold
that we're only a part of a journey
we're only a part of a continuum
and it's not our journey it's the
journey of
all of those people who came before us
yep
and legacy is not what we leave behind
legacy is how much we carried it forward
in pursuit my legacy is not what i left
behind
my legacy is and i moved down the path
ten feet in my lifetime yep and then i
passed the torch to you to try and carry
it
a little further down and i think we
completely misunderstand what legacy
means
that it's actually nothing to do with us
what's your legacy
ask me what what the legacy of those who
came before me and i'll tell you what
mine is
yep because the cause is not mine it was
established long before me
i agree i agree i i don't think i could
say it any better
i appreciate you defining what i
have as courage and i hope it's true
and if it is i could always use a little
bit more
every day
well i'll go with you all right let's do
it i love you
there's not a single time i talk to you
where i don't learn something or come
away just a little wiser see now you're
doing the thing that my friend laurie
did
when i stood at the bottom of the
mountain with a hot cocoa
i'm like wow really yeah that's i love
that thank you
thank you thank you for saying that
[Music]
the thing that i took away from this
conversation was that pursuit
doesn't have to be something lofty it
doesn't have to be about
vision or cause it could be something
much smaller than that
but for us to have courage you have to
have pursuit
if you enjoyed this podcast and if you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other
you